this is a Fox News Alert Health and
Human Services Secretary Tom Price has
resigned
this comes after he faced a lot of
criticism for his use of taxpayer money
for private flights for more on this we
bring in chief White House correspondent
John Roberts Jessi good afternoon to you
know we sort of saw that the writing was
on the wall two days ago when the
president was asked about this as he was
walking across the South Lawn after
talking to the press on his way to the
helicopter as he was traveling to
Indianapolis for his first tax reform
speech the president was asked are you
going to fire Tom price and he paused
for a second and he turned over his
shoulder and he said we'll see and he
just had that look like I'm angry at
this person and the will see was you
betcha
just not today and then as the president
was leaving this afternoon to add up to
Bedminster New Jersey he was asked a lot
about Tom price it was clear that he was
very very angry and upset over what
price had done in terms of taking those
charter flights because now that the
figure I believe is up over a million
dollars for the cost of the flights that
he took he said it's out of keeping with
the tone and tenor of the Trump
administration we're trying to save
taxpayers money not spend more and we
really sort of knew that the writing was
on the ball when we said are you going
to fire town price that he said we'll
have an announcement later today that
typically means it's a done deal we just
haven't made a public yet and in fact
yes that we found out from a statement
from press secretary Sarah Sanders and I
know you spoke with her earlier this
afternoon I don't know if you talked
about this with her or not then she said
that secretary price actually offered
his resignation earlier this morning and
the president accepted it so it was just
a matter of getting the communications
team together to make the official
announcement this afternoon but when the
president said this afternoon we'll make
an announcement he had already made the
decision all right John thank you very
much I guess we'll see is a code for ear
fired you bet too huh Kimberly yeah we
talked about this the other day
commercial break and we said it Kathleen
Sebelius right had done this I think we
would have been very critical well right
so beef be
fare and the bottom line is look I agree
with the president you know he made a
promise to really drain the swamp and
reform Washington and DC and politics as
we know it so therefore when you see a
situation like this which at least
suggests that there was an abuse that
these charter flights shouldn't have
been taken that this was too much you
know largesse and waste of taxpayer
monies I'm right up that alley and not
Lane I think that's 100% true it's a
fair criticism it was improper obviously
the president would be upset with
something like this you know wouldn't
you yeah and so Tom Hart is offering the
resignation was the right thing to do he
proffered it the president accepted it
that's that so let that be a lesson
learned let's see if that's good enough
for some people are they gonna criticize
anyway yeah they'll probably criticize
anyway well I think when you put the
phrase private jet and politician in the
same sense never good one this is never
good for either party no and you know to
pick up on what Kimberly said I think
there's a lot of pressure on this
president at this moment given that he
had just submitted a tax plan that is
you know people have on the Democratic
side are arguing benefits they're rich
so here he has people on his team and it
looks like they're just living like you
know the high-and-mighty and they don't
really care they're not in touch with
the grassroots I mean the other thing to
say is here I think the failure of the
Obama care repeal did not help Tom price
with President Trump right and so he was
on thin ice in that regard and the final
point I'd make to Jesse is that I mean
there's lots of talk around town that
Monday night at that private session
with donors the president was also
highly critical again of jeff sessions
his attorney general and that does not
seem to be a happy relationship
hopefully he doesn't say we'll see about
he's a good man
did Tom Price say well this is why I did
this he tried and he also said that he
would repay the federal government for
his portion of the flight and it's
basically it got out of control and when
oppressed - secretary not a press
secretary when a cabinet secretary
embarrasses the president and it becomes
like the story and you're off of a
legislative failure hmm you know Tom
prices
probably right that to submit the
resignation I would add one other thing
that it wasn't fake news Politico the
reporters tracked this down they did the
reporting the I'm not saying that they
would be proud like that got a scalp but
yeah Brooke this is what happens in
Washington when you have reporters that
sort of get outside the White House
briefing room stop focusing on
everything that the president's tweeting
and look at what's happening across the
federal government you might find
stories like this too many more stories
like this Gutfeld you fly private
constantly you can understand the allure
of not going through lines and things
like that how ironic that his name is
price and that is what he paid costing
Americans millions we'll be right back
I want to there's a bright side for Tom
price on this count this is a relief
that this is how you lost your job as a
politician if this is not a career
killer I mean if you weren't found in
bed with a horse you know you're gonna
say how did you lose your job well I
flew private everybody's like yeah it's
that sucks
I like private you know so it's like
it's you know it's a bad thing but it's
not the worst thing I don't think most
Americans still don't know who he is you
know I don't even know who he is has his
finger on the pulse of his voters and
this is the exact kind of thing that he
said would not happen in Washington on
his watch them yeah him acting
decisively I think shows that he still
understands his base by the way there's
there's another story like this bubbling
with the VA secretary who apparently was
taking flights at taxpayer expense to go
watch Wimbledon oh wow the movie can win
dinner ok well that's never good